flip-flops are functional and a
necessity this time of year and the las
vegas fashion council and the burn
foundation have joined forces to ensure
everyone's feet are protected rocky is
live now to tell us how we can help hi
rocky
hi jillian yeah it's such an important
time of the year to make sure people's
feet are protected we have nino here
with the burn foundation tell us what
the what you're seeing out there and why
you have this cause you know over the
last couple years we were informed by
nurses over at the burn center that
there is absolutely uh many homeless
people who are walking around especially
in the these temperatures without shoes
and so they came to us with an idea and
said hey let's
why don't we go collect flip flops and
go out and get them to the community so
that we can reduce the exposure which in
turn creates injuries that are
massive
for people of homeless absolutely and
it's it's pavement burns that are the
issue here so how hot can the pavement
get exactly well just think
if the temperature the ambient air is
110 degrees add 30 40 plus degrees to it
and a lot of people are walking around
with socks on so it's not enough i mean
just think about it when you walk out to
your backyard or to grab something and
it's five feet but they're doing it all
the time and so we really needed to be
cognizant and find a way to serve them
uh in a very unique niche of time and
time of the year wow and you guys have
already collected over about 200 pairs
of flip-flops and it just started this
month yeah it's uh we're going to go all
the way through the month
we're going to collect uh
through that i believe the 2nd of july
we've collected over 300 already and
they're going to go to homeless programs
uh fire trucks are going to have them on
there and then
we'll give them out as needed that's
great well you guys saw the qr code and
those still on the screen that's where
you can find out all the locations to
donate your flip flops through july 2nd
and coming